[Musique]
bonjour je vais vous parler d'un grand
classique de l'histoire des sciences
une histoire qui remonte aux années 1880
dans le contexte scientifique qui
précèdent cette histoire on sait déjà
que la lumière est une onde une onde
c'est le déplacement d'une perturbation
dans un milieu comme par exemple les
ondes à la surface de l'eau où est la
perturbation est simplement le niveau de
l'eau ou le son que vous connaissez ou
la perturbation est celle de la pression
et le milieu n'importe quel matériau
n'est plus habituellement pour nous
l'air est donc depuis les années 1800 on
sait que la lumière est dans le même cas
qu'il s'agit d'une onde la question
naturelle qu'on se pose c'est dans quel
milieu cette onde se propage et on va
appeler ce milieu hypothétique les
terres et donc le nom qu'on donne à ce
milieu dans lequel la lumière se déplace
vous savez sans doute que la terre
tourne autour du soleil
mais ce que vous savez sans doute moins
parker c'est la vitesse de sa rotation
orbital et c'est de l'ordre de 30
kilomètres par seconde
donc on s'est d'une part que la lumière
du soleil nous parvient elle le fait en
traversant ce milieu politique
cet éther et on sait aussi que la terre
bouge à 30 kilomètres par seconde et
change tout le long de sa trajectoire la
direction donc l'hypothèse qu'un au
moins un point de leur beat on puisse
sentir le mouvement relatif de la terre
par rapport à la terre sentir en quelque
sorte se vend des terres avec environ
cet ordre de grandeur de 30 kilomètres
par seconde alors 30 kilomètres par
seconde c'est beaucoup ça fait déjà une
bonne brise mais la seule chose qu'on
connaisse et qui se déplace dans les
terres c'est la lumière et la lumière ça
se déplace à 300 mille kilomètres par
seconde donc entre les deux il ya un
rapport dix mille pour la lumière
franchir un cours d'eau avec un courant
de 30 kilomètres par seconde c'est comme
franchir un lac extrêmement calme et
donc pendant longtemps on a cru que la
précision nécessaire pour mettre en
évidence quelques choses étaient bien
trop bien trop importante et c'est donc
ce contexte qu'arrive alpert à branne
mickelson lui il va dire que c'est
possible il va concevoir et réaliser une
expérience qui fait exactement cela
mesurée
vitesse du vent des terres alors comment
ça marche le dispositif de nicholson
donc c'est un dispositif optique qui
fait intervenir la lumière évidemment et
là vous voyez une vue de haut
schématique du dispositif donc vous avez
un rayon lumineux qui arrive en a qui
touche un miroir semi réfléchissant
représenté en bleu donc celui
réfléchissant une partie va être
réfléchie une partie la traverser le
miroir la partie réfléchi va faire un
aller-retour en baissé en touchant un
miroir oh et la partie qui traverse va
faire un aller-retour en des voeux qui
touche un miroir à droite et une partie
des deux signaux vont se recombiner en
ait fait son rêve qu'on va chercher à
observer quelque chose de particulier
donc on voit que ce dispositif à deux
bras deux trajets perpendiculaire l'un à
l'autre possible pour la lumière et on
va la faire en sorte en fait que c'est
la longueur de ses deux bras soit
exactement la même on va en mettre un
dans le sens du vent des terres supposé
et autres perpendiculaire l'analogique
on donne pour expliquer le
fonctionnement qui est derrière c'est
celle de deux nageurs vous imaginez deux
nageurs parfaitement identiques l'un
essayant de faire un aller-retour dans
un cours d'eau perpendiculaire au
courant et l'autre faisant un
aller-retour dans le sens du courant
qu'à moitié à contre-courant l'autre
moitié dans le sens du courant et il se
trouve que dans ces conditions là si les
deux nageurs sont absolument identiques
c'est celui qui se déplace
perpendiculairement au courant qui
arrivera un peu en premier qu'on observe
un décalage
je vous laisse faire les calculs si ça
vous intéresse et donc dans l'expérience
de mickelson basse et même principal
c'est la lumière qu'on utilise à la
place des nageurs et le vent des terres
qu'on utilise à la place du courant et
on espère observé un décalage au bout on
a dit que la lumière était une onde
donc c'est à dire qu'en pratique c'est
vraiment ce que vous pouvez imaginer un
voir la lumière comme des petites vagues
dans l'espace mais c'est un phénomène
qui est très petit pour la lumière
visible par exemple c'est de l'ordre de
5 100 nanomètres donc 512 m c'est la
taille entre une vague est la suivante
est simple environ cinq dix millième de
millimètre et c'est parfait parce qu'en
fait on va utiliser cette précision là à
notre avantage donc dispositif de
nicholson lorsque deux vagues de zone se
recombiner qu'elle arrive synchronisée
on a les boss qui arrivent en même temps
que les poches vous voyez à gauche et
les creux qui arrivent en même temps que
les creux oncle tous s'amplifie et on
observe une augmentation de l'intensité
et si ça arrive légèrement décalé
on observe les bosses en même temps
qu'une partie des creux et donc le
signal s'atténuer
il faut parfois totalement et donc une
baisse on a une baisse de l'intensité
donc dans le dispositif de mickelson
il suffit que le vent des terres décale
l'arrivée d'un signal lumineux de
l'ordre de 5 10 millièmes de millimètre
même du dix millième de millimètre pour
qu'on voit quelque chose
voyez ici un schéma j'ai pas trouvé de
photos du premier dispositif de
mickelson qui est en euros donc on
reconnaît les deux bras du dispositif
avec au bout de chaque bras un miroir
qui va servir à indiquer la lumière donc
c'est un dispositif qui est installé sur
un pied ça lui permet de tourner ça a
deux avantages le premier expérimental
on va faire une série de mesures sans
bouger l'appareil et après on va refaire
une autre en le tournant de 90 degrés
comme ça en l'air ce le rôle de chaque
bras et ça permet d'être sûr que la
conclusion de l'expérience en fait elle
dépend pas du dispositif mais bien de ce
qu'on mesure puis une autre utilité
c'est que si on peut le tourner petit à
petit plutôt que de voir deux points on
va voir une variation l'intensité tout
au long de la rotation du dispositif car
évidemment un dispositif au tir aussi
précis à régler c'est totalement l'enfer
donc nicholson il va entre autres citer
la température il suffit qu'un des deux
bras du dispositif soit un centième de
degré plus choc l'autre pour que la
dilatation du métal engendre un décalage
qui serait plus grande que les faits
qu'on veut mettre en évidence on a aussi
l'activité humaine qui est un problème
le dispositif est installé dans une cave
mais les sabots des chevaux à 100 m dans
une rue font des vibrations qui
suffisent à rendre le dispositif
inutilisable et enfin on a le fait que
ce dispositif
il est relativement flexible et il faut
le tour n'est donc même si les
imperceptiblement flexible et fait métal
et bien le tournée est impossible à
chaque fois qu il le tourne tout se
dérègle
mais bon en refaisant le dispositif
plusieurs fois en décalant l'expérience
d'emplacements trois fois et en
effectuant les mesures la nuit nicholson
va réussir en 1881 il mène avec succès
son expérience et y donne une valeur à
la vitesse du vent des terres ils
arrivent à mesurer le vent des terres et
que va-t-il trouver absolument rien dans
l'expérience de mickelson
on n'observe pas de valeur de vitesse du
vent des terres alors évidemment ça ne
s'arrête pas là car vous voyez qu avec
quelque chose qui est aussi précis c'est
difficile d'être cru on peut imaginer
que l'écart expérimental est trop grand
par rapport à la précision du système
est nécessaire et c'est dans ce contexte
qu'arrive un deuxième vingt deuxième
personnage qui est edward eliane morlaix
et lui son idée ça va être de rendre un
dispositif qui était déjà extrêmement
pénible à régler à cause de sa précision
en un dispositif encore plus précis et
c'est exactement ce qu'ils vont faire à
deux donc là vous voyez une photo du
nouveau dispositif donc à la place
d'avoir deux bras de métal on a un
énorme bloc qui est beaucoup plus rigide
donc sur lequel est installé toujours
les miroirs dans deux directions
possibles
voyez le schéma en dessous le dispositif
est installé sur une cuve de mercure qui
est donc à température ambiante un métal
liquide cette cuve de mercure repose sur
une énorme pierre de granit
donc c'est un dispositif flottant ça lui
permet deux choses de s'isoler des
vibrations et de pouvoir tourner il
suffit de lui donner une petite
impulsion et tourner pendant plusieurs
minutes sans qu'on n'y touche très
lentement en effectuant un tour si ma
mémoire est bonne tout les 6 minutes
alors la grande amélioration du
dispositif c'est pas tout ça c'est
d'avoir remarqué que plus le dispositif
est grand plus vous laisser de temps aux
deux rayons lumineux de se décaler mais
construire un dispositif qui ferait 10
mètres de diamètre
ce serait extrêmement difficile donc
l'astuce ça va être installé toute une
série de miroirs
avant on avait un aller retour de la
lumière dans chaque direction et
maintenant on en a juste plusieurs donc
vous voyez le schéma en haut à droite
qui représente tous les allers retours
et à la fin on réunit les deux les deux
trajets de la lumière et donc ici avec
toute cette chose on a une précision qui
est dix fois supérieure à celle de
l'expérience de mickelson
seul je vous laisse imaginer la
difficulté pour régler une dizaine de
miroirs dans toutes les directions et
sûr que la longueur est la même avec la
précision demandé mais au cours de
l'année 1887
ils vont réussir et ils vont mener à
terme leurs expériences et mesurer la
vitesse du vent des terres ils vont le
faire deux fois à trois mois
d'intervalle pour être sûr que la mesure
n'était pas de la position de la terre
sur son orbite
si vous vous souvenez de la raison pour
laquelle on faisait ça au début et que
vont-ils trouver absolument rien dans
l'expérience de mickelson morlaix on
n'observe pas non plus de vitesse du
vent des terres l'expérience de
mickelson morlaix est ce qu'on appelle
en sciences une expérience négative
sa conclusion est qu'il n'ya pas de vent
des terres mais ici plus précisément du
coup qu'il n'y a pas des terres et que
la lumière est une ode sans support
cette conclusion sera un des piliers qui
va soutenir la révolution scientifique
qui sont suivra au cours du 20e siècle
commençant par la révolution introduite
par einstein et la relativité
ça nous amène une première remarque sur
le fonctionnement de la science la
science apprend de la surprise de la
contradiction et de ses erreurs et dans
le cas de l'expérience de mickelson
morlaix elle le fait sous sa forme la
plus pure
ce n'est pas qu'on observe quelque chose
qui vient s'ajouter à la théorie et
comme s'y attendait pas c'est qu'elle
sait qu'on n'observe pas quelque chose
que la théorie prédisaient une autre
remarque qu'on peut faire sur le
fonctionnement de la science sait
l'importance de la transparence et de la
documentation
car faire l'expérience c'est important
mais c'est encore mieux si on arrive à
en faire profiter la communauté
scientifique et donc c'est à dire à
faire en sorte qu on vous croit donc je
vous laisse imaginer la réputation qu'il
faut pour convaincre avec votre compte
rendu quand vous dites aux mesures rien
que les gens vont plutôt vous croire et
d'irma en fait il ya rien que simplement
penser que vous avez mal mesuré mais la
documentation
ça ne sert pas qu'à ça ça sert aussi à
quelque chose de très important qu'est
la réplication et cette histoire à une
suite car tout au long du xxème siècle
on va avoir toute une série
d'expériences une vingtaine j'en ai
trouvé au total qui reprennent soit le
fonctionnement du dispositif de
mickelson morlaix soit quelque chose de
totalement différent
parfois c'est pour tester des conditions
qui pourraient être objecté dans les
dispositifs de mickelson mort à l'oeil
les tests
dans une cave non pourrait dire que les
parois de la cale font obstacle au vent
des terres donc y aura des versions de
l'expérience qui seront à l'extérieur on
peut remarquer notablement que morlaix
recommence lui-même une expérience en
1902 et une autre en 1904 morlaix est un
scientifique qui doute et pour un
scientifique
c'est une qualité et on peut aussi
remarquer l'expérience de 1973 qui est
intéressante même si elle fonctionne sur
un fonctionnement totalement différent
en fait parce qu'elle serait capable de
mesurer une vitesse du vent des terres
de l'ordre de 3 cm par seconde
donc je vous rappelle qu'au début on
avait du mal à mesurer une vitesse de
vent des terres de 30 kilomètres par
seconde est que dans la dernière version
de 1973 on pourrait mesurer une vitesse
de vent des terres de trois centimètres
par seconde alors qu'est ce que toutes
ces expériences vont trouver quelle est
la valeur du vent des terres qu'ils
mesurent toujours rien absolument rien
n'y a pas de vitesse devant des terres
qui sont têtus mais c'est comme ça donc
ça ça nous amène sur une dernière
remarque sur le fonctionnement de la
science c'est que la science apprend
apprend aussi de la réplication
invérifiées encore et toujours que la
théorie fonctionne c'est très important
je imaginez le travail qu'il faut faire
derrière la longue série de l'expérience
qu'on a vu juste avant le l'effort que
ça représente et chaque expérience ne
nous apprend en fait en quelque sorte
rien de plus que ce qu'on soupçonne déjà
et c'est essentiel
tous ces scientifiques qui dédie une
partie de leur travail a répliqué
quelques choses ont très peu de chances
de devenir célèbre grâce à une
réplication car une réplication c'est
c'est généralement pas une observation
disruptive mais leur travail est
essentiel vérifier encore et toujours
que la théorie fonctionne c'est le prix
à payer pour être sûr de converger vers
davantage de vérité alors ça apporte
aussi quelques questions un peu
philosophique
quand est-ce qu'il faut persévérer dans
l'expérience quand est-ce qu'il faut
s'arrêter et revenir sur la théorie donc
il ya deux exemples celui du boson de
higgs pendant de nombreuses années on a
fait beaucoup d'expériences pour mettre
en évidence le boson de higgs jamais
rien trouvé
puis au final on en fait l'une et ont le
nez
donc là c'était justifié et la
conclusion n'était pas celle des
premières expériences et dans le cas de
la matière noire c'est une question qui
est ouverte
on suppose que celle ci serait faite de
particules faiblement interagissant avec
la matière et jusqu'à présent toutes les
expériences menées même d expérience
extrêmement précises n'ont jamais réussi
à rien détecté donc faut-il considérer
qu'il faut faire une énième expérience
ou revenir sur la théorie
mystère la conclusion en dehors de ce
que ça nous dit sur le fonctionnement de
la science l'importance de
l'apprentissage des erreurs de la
surprise la documentation et de la
réplication
moi je trouve qu'à la conclusion
personnelle que je préfère à
l'expérience de 1000 personnes morlaix
est là c'est paradoxal car pour une
expérience qui est très pratique
moi ce que je préfère en fait c'est ce
qu'elle nous dit sur le plan théorique
parfois pour faire les plus grandes
découvertes et les plus grandes
révolutions scientifiques
il suffit juste de comprendre qu'il n'ya
en fait rien à voir merci
[Applaudissements]